>>> FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER
YOU'D LIKE TO LET MACINTOSH
SPEAK FOR ITSELF.
>> HELLO, I'M MACINTOSH.
IT IS GREAT TO GET OUT OF THAT
BAG.
>> WELL, COMPUTER INTELLIGENCE
HAS COME A LONG WAY, ALTHOUGH
THAT JOKE PROBABLY COULD HAVE
BEEN WRITTEN TODAY BY CHATGPT
AND WITH STEVE JOBS INTRODUCING
THE MACINTOSH COMPUTER 40 YEARS
AGO, HIS FRIEND AND APPLE
CO-FOUNDER STEVE WOZNIAK AMONG A
CHORUS ON TECH LEAD EFFORTS
CALLING FOR A PAUSE TO ON
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE CITING
PROFOUND RISKS TO HUMANITY.
SAMSUNG THE LATEST TO BAN A.I.
ON THEIR DEVICES.
OTHERS WROTE THAT A.I.
DEVELOPERS ARE LOCKED IN AN
ALL-OUT -- IN AN OUT-OF-CONTROL,
I SHOULD SAY, RACE TO DEVELOP
AND DEPLOY EVER MORE POWERFUL
DIGITAL MINDS THAT NO ONE, NOT
EVEN THEIR CREATORS, CAN
UNDERSTAND, PREDICT OR RELIABLY
CONTROL.
PEOPLE LISTEN WHEN WOZNIAK TALKS
ABOUT TECH.
HE DESIGNED THE APPLE ONE AND
TWO COMPUTERS THAT HELPED PUT
APPLE ON THE MAP.
APPLE ONE WAS BUILT IN JOBS'
PARENTS' GARAGE IN 1966.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
PLENTY EARLY OUT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> PLENTY EARLY.
WE APPRECIATE YOU GETTING UP
EARLY.
YOU ARE WORRIED, ELON MUSK IS
WORRIED, THE MAN FROM GOOGLE,
THE GRANDFATHER OF A.I. QUIT
BECAUSE OF HOW WORRIED HE IS.
WHAT TO PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW?
>> WELL, YOU GOT A LITTLE BIT
WRONG ABOUT ME.
I AM NOT LIKE WORRIED, I BELIEVE
IN FEAR.
I JUST BELIEVE WHEN SOME
POWERFUL TECHNOLOGY IS
INTRODUCED WE SHOULD LOOK AT --
ALMOST ALL TECHNOLOGY BRINGS
GOOD TO US AND BAD THINGS AND WE
SHOULD BE RESPONSIBLE AND STUDY
THESE THINGS AND KIND OF PREPARE
PEOPLE FOR WHAT'S COMING AND
TAKE STEPS MAYBE TO KEEP IT FROM
BEING TOO HORRIBLE AND BAD.
FOR EXAMPLE, YOU KNOW, LOOK AT
HOW MANY BAD PEOPLE OUT THERE
ARE HITTING US WITH SPAM AND
TRYING TO GET OUR PASSWORDS AND
TAKE OVER OUR ACCOUNTS AND MESS
UP OUR LIVES AND, YOU KNOW, NOW
A.I. IS ANOTHER MORE POWERFUL
TOOL.
IT'S GOING TO BE USED BY THOSE
PEOPLE, YOU KNOW, FOR BASICALLY
REALLY EVIL PURPOSES.
I HATE TO SEE TECHNOLOGY BEING
USED THAT WAY.
IT SHOULDN'T BE, AND SOME,
PROBABLY SOME TYPES OF
REGULATION ARE NEEDED.
REGULATION IS TELLING PARTIES
THAT ARE PRODUCING THINGS YOU
WILL OBEY, YOU WILL NOT DO
CERTAIN BAD THINGS.
IT'S LIKE OUR BILL OF RIGHTS.
THE CONGRESS WILL NOT PASS
CERTAIN TYPES OF LAWS.
AND, YOU KNOW, YOU CALL THAT
REGULATION.
NOT LIKE STOPPING YOU FROM DOING
YOUR BUSINESS.
SAYING NO, YOU HAVE TO HAVE
ETHICAL CONCERNS.
>> I AM CURIOUS HOW YOU THINK
A.I. HAS EVOLVED SINCE RECENT
YEARS.
IN 2018, YOU DID AN INTERVIEW
THAT I WATCHED YESTERDAY.
YOU SAID THIS ABOUT A.I.
>> NO MACHINE SITS DOWN AND SAYS
WHAT SHOULD I WORK ON?
HUMANS TELL IT WHAT TO WORK ON.
WE ARE BUILDING TECHNOLOGIES
THAT WILL MAKE LIFE EASIER FOR
US.
WHERE IS THE LACK OF JOBS?
AT LEAST WHERE I COME FROM IN
THE UNITED STATES, YOU KNOW,
PEOPLE HAVE JOBS.
>> AND NOW WE SEE WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING AND ALSO TALKING ABOUT
REGULATION.
COULD THERE BE GLOBAL REGULATION
FOR SOMETHING LIKE THIS
TECHNOLOGY?
>> NO, THERE NEVER CAN BE.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
TECHNOLOGY HAS SO MANY BAD
SIDES.
I OFTEN SAY THOSE THAT BROUGHT
US THIS DIGITAL WORLD, YOU KNOW,
WHEN I LOOK BACK AT SOME OF THE
EASIER LIFE DAYS AND LESS
WORRIES ABOUT THIS STUFF AND
THINGS WORKED MORE, I SAY THOSE
WHO BROUGHT THE DIGITAL
REVOLUTION SHOULD BE EXECUTED
OR, WORSE YET, MAKE THEM LIVE IN
IT.
SO, YEAH, YOU CANNOT REGULATE
BAD PEOPLE VERY WELL.
COULD A.I. BE EMPLOYED TO SPOT
ALL THESE LITTLE TRICKY LITTLE
WORDED SPAMS THAT ARE TRYING TO
GET YOUR PASSWORDS?
IT'S NEVER USED THAT WAY.
IT'S USED BY PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
MAKE A NAME FOR THEMSELVES OR
MAKE MONEY FOR THEMSELVES AND
THAT NEVER QUITE GOES AS WELL AS
IT SHOULD.
>> I WANT TO TALK --
>> IT'S LIKE LOVE OVER MONEY.
I MEAN, I HAVE FEELINGS.
I HAVE EMOTIONS.
IF I READ A CERTAIN STORY I
MIGHT CRY.
DOES A.I. CRY?
YOU KNOW, SO IT'S -- EMPLOYED
FOR THE BENEFIT OF HUMANS.
WHEN WE STARTED EVEN WITHOUT A
COMPUTER, A PERSONAL COMPUTER
WAS A TOOL THAT WOULD LET HUMANS
DO MORE THAN THEY EVER DID
BEFORE AND BE MORE CAPABLE AND
IN CONTROL OF THEIR OWN DESTINY
MORE, AND IT'S SORT OF LIKE HARD
TO JUDGE IT THAT WAY NOW.
DO WE GET TO THAT WORLD WHERE
WE'RE HAPPIER THAN 10,000 YEARS
AGO?
NOTHING TELLS ME THAT'S TRUE.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
WOULD DO BECAUSE THE FACT I
MENTIONED THE GODFATHER OF A.I.
AS HE IS KNOWN, JEFFREY HINTON,
LEFT GOOGLE THE LAST WEEK.
HE SAID THE IDEA THAT THIS
STUFF, A.I., COULD ACTUALLY GET
SMARTER THAN PEOPLE, A FEW
PEOPLE BELIEVED THAT.
BUT MOST PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WAS
WAY OFF AND I THOUGHT IT WAS WAY
OFF.
I THOUGHT IT WAS 30 TO 50 YEARS,
LONGER AWAY.
OBVIOUSLY, I KNOW LONGER THINK
THAT.
YOU SAID MAYBE WE HAVE TO TAKE
CHANGES.
THIS LETTER TALKS ABOUT PAUSING
THINGS.
THIS IS WHAT GOOGLE'S CEO,
RIGHT, WHERE HINTON WORKED,
SUNDAY DARPY CHR TOLD ME IN 2019
ABOUT SLOWING DOWN ON A.I. IF
THEY HAVE TO.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU ARE BASICALLY SAYING WE
HAVE TO WEIGH OUR TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCEMENT AND COMPETITIVENESS
WITH WHAT IT AMERICANS FOR
HUMANITY?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
IT'S WHAT SOCIETY EXPECTS US TO
DO.
>> THAT WAS THEN.
THIS IS NOW.
SHOULD GOOGLE SLOW IT DOWN?
AND THE COMPETITORS?
>> WELL, JEFFREY HINTON IS, YOU
KNOW, HE WON THE TORINO AWARD,
THE NOBEL PRIZE OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE.
I WOULD DIE FOR THAT.
I GOT ONE CLOSE TO IT.
BUT SO -- AND THESE PEOPLE THAT
WERE INVOLVED IN A.I. FROM THE
START, HE IS, OBVIOUSLY, ONE OF
THEM AND THE WOMAN, THE CTO AT
OAKLAND A.I.
THEY PUT OUT -- YES, THERE ARE
CONCERNS, YES, WE SHOULD HAVE
REGULATION.
THEY ARE CLOSE TO IT.
THEY ARE THE PRODUCERS OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY.
YOU NORMAL PEOPLE OUT THERE, WE
SHOULD BE TOLD, HERE IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS GENERATED BY
A.I. SO WE CAN SAY I PREFER TO
KNOW THINGS THAT ARE ALWAYS
RIGHT AND NOT SOME THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT UNTRUSTABLE AND
FLAKY.
I LIKE THE TRUST.
>> WELL, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THE POLITICAL ASPECT?
WE SAW PRESIDENT BIDEN ANNOUNCE
HE IS RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION.
REPUBLICANS RESPONDED WITH AN
A.I.-GENERATED AD, SAYING IT
WOULD BE A DYSTOPIAN FUTURE IF
HE IS ELECT LTD.
HE WAS CRITICIZED.
ARE YOU OR WORRIED ABOUT THE
EFFECT A.I. HAVE ON THE
POLITICS.
>> IT'S BENEFICIAL LIKE BEING A
GOOD REPORTER AND WE HUMANS
SHOULD BE THE EDITOR.
WHEN THAT'S NOT THE CASE, WE
WILL HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS.
YOU KNOW, AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW,
A.I. BEING USED TO, I DON'T
KNOW, DEEPFAKES.
MAKING SOMEBODY SOUND LIKE A
PERSON YOU KNOW IN THEIR VOICE
AND TAKING ADVANTAGE OF A
MOTHER.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT RECENTLY AND
THERE IS GOING TO BE A LOT MORE
OF THAT THAN EVER BEFORE.
TRICKING YOU ANYTHING THINGS.
TRICKING IS GOING TO BE EASIER
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO TRICK YOU.
WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY -- WE
ARE NOT MAKING ANY CHANGES IN
THAT REGARD.
WE ARE JUST ASSUMING THAT THE
LAWS WE HAVE WILL TAKE CARE OF
IT.
SO I AM A LITTLE -- YOU KNOW, I
AM WORRIED ABOUT PEOPLE BEING
ABUSED.
FORTUNATELY, I AM NOT POLITICAL,
BUT, YES, A.I. COULD BE USED TO
SWAY AND MAKE IT SEEM LIKE
POLITICAL TRUTHS ARE THERE.
PEOPLE ARE VERY DIFFERENT AND
A.I. COMES OUT WITH A BROADCAST
THAT SAYS WE ARE ALL THE SAME, I
AM TRUTH, YOU KNOW, HERE IS A
DEEP UNDERSTANDING OF SOMETHING.
WELL, YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M
GOING TO FEEL LIKE EATING
TONIGHT, YOU KNOW?
AND A.I. IS NOT LIKE THAT.
IT MISSES A LOT OF EMOTIONAL I
DRIVE.
A LOT OF THE DECISIONS WE MAKE
HAVE AN EMOTIONAL CONTENT AND
A.I. WILL KIND YOU HAVE ACT LIKE
HERE IS A DECISION TO MAKE, YOU
KNOW, AND IT'S JUST KIND OF LIKE
MONTONE, SORT OF BORING.
>> WE HAVE SO MANY QUESTIONS.
STEVE, WE HOPE YOU WILL COME
BACK.
>> COULD I ASK ONE MORE BEFORE
YOU GO ACTUALLY?
ONE THING WE TALK ABOUT HERE IS
ELON MUSK.
DO YOU TALK TO ELON MUSK EVER?
>> I HAVE NEVER MET HIM AND
SPOKE WITH HIM.
I ADMIRE SOME THINGS HE HAS DONE
FOR THE WORLD, ELECTRIC CARS.
BUT, YOU KNOW, HIS REAL
MOTIVATIONS, IS HE A PURIST OF
TRYING TO CLEAN THE AIR AND ALL
THAT IS SHADOWED BY A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS AND HE BASICALLY
GOT A LOT OF MONEY FROM MYSELF
FOR A CAR I BELIEVE -- A CAR
WOULD DRIVE ITSELF ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BY THE END OF 2016789.
OH, I HAD TO UPGRADE TO THAT
MODEL, $50,000.
AND THEN IT WOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING.
IT WOULDN'T MAKE IT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
HERE, WE HAVE A IN YOU ONE WITH
EIGHT CAMERAS THAT WILL MAKE IT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BY 2017.
I BELIEVED THOSE THINGS AND IT'S
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO REALITY AND
BOY IF YOU WANT A STUDY OF A.I.
GONE WRONG AND TAKING A LOT OF
CLAIMS AND TRYING TO KILL YOU
EVERY CHANCE YOU CAN, GET A
TESLA.
>> WOW.
ANY THOUGHTS HOW HE IS RUNNING
TWITTER?
>> WELL, IT'S KIND OF BUMBLING.
I CAN'T SAY GOOD OR BAD.
I AM NOT REALLY THERE.
AND TWITTER, YOU KNOW, PROBABLY
NEEDS A LOT OF CHANGE AND
REVAMPING IN MOST PEOPLE'S EYES.
WE WILL SEE.
TWITTER IS A SOCIAL NETWORK AND
I AVOID THE SOCIAL NETWORKS.
I DON'T KNOW, YOU CAN GET SO
DISTORTED AND GET IN GROUPS AND
PEOPLE ARE FREE TO CRITICIZE
EVERYBODY AND THEY ARE SORT OF
ANONYMOUS AND AREN'T JUDGED.
PEOPLE CAN DO ILLEGAL THINGS
VERY EASILY ON YOUTUBE OR
TWITTER.
VERY ILLEGAL THINGS AND THE
COMPANIES WON'T DO ANYTHING TO
EVEN SHUT IT DOWN OTHER THAN YOU
CAN REPORT IT LIKE YOU CAN
REPORT ANYTHING IT TAKES THAT
ONE INSTANCE DOWN AND ANOTHER
POPS UP LIKE WHAC-A-MOLE.
THE WAY THE SOCIAL WEB WORKS
BROUGHT A LOT OF NEGATIVES.
YOU CAN SEE THAT MOVIE "THE
SOCIAL DILEMMA", AND HOW THEY
TREAT THE USERS TO GET MORE
BUSINESS.
LOVE VERSUS MONEY.
>> VERY IMPORTANT.
TESLA WOULD PROBABLY DISPUTE
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE CARS.
I KNOW YOU EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION
BEFORE WITH WHAT ELON SAID WHAT
THE CAPABILITY WAS.
FASCINATING CONVERSATION.
STEVE, WE LOVE HAVING YOU ON.